hello and welcome to this video playing
pd from denmark and this is a good score
six out of six so let's keep up the good
work okay that line is pretty nice for
white doing white good chances on the
queenside we will see what he does okay
of this line tries for a quick night to
before it's interesting
very often you can just play ruga a form
and reply to that I might have a five in
this case hmm that's not completely
clear that this is helpful hmm it's not
clear to me but anyway I need to speed
up a little bit like night before a4a
593 hey five is the thing I click go
back there should be two actually this
is an interesting way to play basically
winning winning material right after
Bishop d2 how is he not losing stuff at
least it will cost the porn I forgot
about that when I was initially
calculating this line that I can go back
it doesn't look very heavy Bishop f4 it
back but just good but for concrete
reasons Bishop takes before threatens to
win over peace so he has to do something
something drastic here maybe b5
something like that and okay I cannot
move the rook unfortunately otherwise i
would like to do that no I have to take
now is God e6 still there is this b6
porn that still he has to get back
somehow how to do that 95
yeah let's see and something like so
it's just a very concrete position I can
try to exploit the UH pneumonia state of
blacks position quickly maybe 95 and
then III 93 or something like that now
maybe 94 hmm tough to say what's what
the best is maybe this isn't so great
actually 97 as maybe a move for him
okay i can probably take play b7 ok 97
Bishop d7 and b7 like unit lame and have
to play okay it takes with a king well
that's not such a big deal then if we
take sit with the king how to do this
now
it's a little bit difficult to get rid
of this the night on before night 83
King be one night see to this kind of
thing maybe 1 93 92 is this a very it's
very direct maybe that's the way to do
it at the end a 5 will be the problem is
still as a pawn down there with them
pawn on d6 maybe c5 know is a move for
him yeah that could be that could be
good see you fire four possible bishops
is six nope not doing it okay so I see I
want to really get rid of that piece
looks a little bit unharmonious I hope
there is no direct way to make use of
that got a triple beep on it's no beauty
now yes it's not that terrible fail
because of my
yeah my less than perfect development I
came out here well he can take and fix
my pawn structure and this bishop well
it can go to BBM athlon to a c8 doesn't
help that much ok I have to get some
kind of development yeah it's not it's
not so bad fam ok I'm take now or let
him take him I probably have to let him
take that and now in 1485 ok for see
biking ok check I'm getting at the
before poor now this is the thing
slightly weaker Paul will be form and if
I get that that's a strong
and yeah it will be difficult for him to
defend don't see how he's going to do it
okay yeah it's a good move I take it
that c5 if this is not but I can do this
it's not so bad okay well this is this
is perfectly fine for me I was thinking
is good place for sure if 6t i will i
will get the pawn so take it right away
or I have okay for to cover so I think I
can take it's not a big problem six
takes takes takes I'm winning the king
of porn ending so I'm sure that should
book and then behind this a pawn some a
book ending some Luke ending should win
like Bishop takes rook takes before okay
a drogue a4 should be pretty simple win
least I don't see a problem and time
working good move stopping stopping me
mmm that was a good move ok I have to
move my king somehow that doesn't look
right to be honest anyway my time thinks
III looks weird actually anyway I had to
had to move
you
check
that's critical still critical from like
I think we should Bishop the aid okay
but should be aid it's a tempo oh now
that's it that's losing I think my hope
that should lose its running out of
moves now I a shaky and kim i didn't
play that well check check black
forfeits on time I wasn't well played I
should this will this end game I should
check lucky I should probably win quite
quite straightforwardly at least I mean
he not sure here because he five was
good but I think later after he plays he
fired I should win this pretty easily
but I didn't didn't do it yeah maybe
okay the engine just takes here yeah
it's also a lot stronger because now we
get rooks get to get bishops traded or
he takes and I've got rook everyone who
kept seven so I did not need to spend
the time on their move I was under
estimating this position this was a good
move blocking the pawn and setting
problems that the computer wants to play
king c2 am I didn't play it because of
that it seemed wrong to me but it keeps
a pretty substantial advantage and this
is now and then [ __ ] holy some kind of
draw because he he has here yes take
stakes yes Bishop piayed of course this
is a thing to draw this is this is
losing ogy can go g5 and I'm losing hoji
Falls bad i forgot about g5 wow that's a
bad move I have to start with this and
I'm winning
now he is running out of moves now like
this in this while chief oh wow I
totally forgot about g500 terrible move
whoa wow that old wrong autumn that
losses due to f6 wow so only have four
wins that's interesting
he runs out of moves while interesting
yeah i was i was thinking that this
should use but I g4 was mindless I mean
okay I'd only 20 seconds but still this
is I mean I'm to to see that f four
winns age for losers mmm and that feels
tricky to me but G bamboo is just
ridiculous hair g5 is quite obvious very
bad and gameplay never lucky game okay
thanks for watching